hi dina how are you i'm great
i'm really excited for our pair
programming session today
yeah development has really picked up
here at
big corp limited since we started these
sessions
uh what are we working on today dina
well
it's kind of tricky and i'm not really
sure how to do it
my manager wants to launch a private
internal wiki
on gcp ah what do you mean
well she doesn't want it to be
accessible from the public internet
oh that doesn't sound so bad well the
tricky part
is that she also wants our cloud
function microservices to be able to
write to the wiki ah sounds like we need
to set up a serverless
vpc connector we can host private
applications but like this wiki
or even databases on virtual machines or
clusters
in google compute engine and with a
serverless vpc connector we can connect
to any of these private
[Music]
resources
[Music]
all right let's get back to the issue at
hand dina
uh to start uh would you set up a
private wiki
in google compute engine okay
i'm ready all right uh so
if you click uh on the uh navigation
menu there
exactly and then click marketplace
and search for media wiki
and the one i usually use is the one
from
[Music]
yeah bitnami that's the one yeah
let's set it up as a public service and
so this is all defaults
throughout uh so we can test it okay
okay so we're just gonna leave all of
these just as they are
and deploy
very nice so this will take a few
minutes
wow that was easy yeah
let's give it a minute so the external
ip
address will start working now on the
upper right there you see it's a site
address that's the external ip address
so paste that into your browser and test
if we can see
this media wiki in installation
okay
hey it works yeah great
now let's update the network settings so
that it no longer has a public ip
address
so you can do that by clicking the
navigation menu upper left and then go
to compute engine
and uh click your virtual machine should
show up here
can you make the font a little bit
bigger dina
thank you uh easier for me to see so
then scroll down to network
interfaces okay
and uh there it is okay and
for that one click uh nick 0 there
oh sorry click edit at the top of that
oh okay
i'll go back yeah
sorry i gave the wrong instructions
yeah now click the exact little pen
there
and here it says external ip we have an
ephemeral ip address so let's set this
to
none okay this means we won't be able
undone
and then save at the bottom of the page
very good and let's give that a minute
for the network
change to take effect so now
we turned off the external ephemeral ip
address uh now check
the uh network address for that media
wiki again
it's from the public internet see if we
can reach it
looks like it doesn't exist anymore hmm
i'm going to try the private ip address
oh that's right it has a private
internal one as well
yeah can i look at that one
this one also doesn't work perfect
this is just what we wanted so this
media wiki instance still exists
but it's off of the public internet uh
these network settings will work with
any kind of private service or
infrastructure that we might want to set
up
this could now it's a media wiki but it
could be a mail server or
say a mongodb instance or something like
it
okay now we're going to connect to it so
next we'll set up the connector
we do go back to cloud console and uh
click that
navigation menu and then go to vpc
network
and uh serverless vpc connector perfect
and let's create a new
connector there at the top
okay
what settings should i use uh let's go
with the defaults
okay i'm just going to copy this one
that they give here
[Music]
okay
excellent now we have a vpc connector
that we can access from serverless
so for the final step let's set up a
cloud function
which will use this vpc connector to
access the media wiki server so go to
cloud functions
okay create a new function
sounds good
um what kind of function should it be uh
let's
uh for now let's uh go with http trigger
type
so we will use the browser to trigger
this function
and then this function will access the
hidden media wiki server
okay sounds good um do i need to worry
about any of these settings down here
oh right good thing you noticed in the
advanced sections would you go to
connections and select the new
serverless connector that you just
created
cool
yeah and this will ensure that all
traffic from the cloud function
all outbound network calls from this
cloud function will go through
your this private connector that you
just set up
okay so if it's using the private
connection that means
it will be able to reach that private ip
address
for the wiki yep that's correct
okay cool um well then i'm gonna put
that private address
into our function i'm gonna grab it from
here
uh-huh
okay i'm gonna deploy um okay
so just to say what i just did i put the
private address
into our function here um and then we're
going to trigger the function
by accessing the url which will then
call the rest api the media wiki server
using the private ip address
right yeah perfect yeah that sounds
great let's deploy the function
this will take a few minutes cool
so now let's test it go to the http
trigger address of this function and
by doing that you're calling the
function and the function
in turn calls the wiki rest api
it works huzzah oh you were right
it wasn't so tricky after all another
successful pair programming session for
big
corp limited at this rate we're gonna
have to rename it big corp
unlimited
[Music]
you